we've made comparisons between Donald
Trump and disgraced Republican President
Richard Nixon on a few fronts and the
ways in which Donald Trump's White House
debacle is becoming Nick Sounion are
growing and I want to talk about some of
those ways with you right now
first like the Trump firing Comey
incident and I've mentioned this one to
you before Richard Nixon fired the
independent prosecutor that was
investigating Watergate Archibald Cox
that was known as the Saturday night
massacre I told you about that last week
second during Nixon's famous series of
interviews with David Frost in 1977 when
he was asked about his illegal
activities as President Nixon responded
that in a phrase that now lives in
infamy that when the President does it
it isn't illegal I'll remind you what
that sounded like when the President
does it that means that it is not
illegal Donald Trump is sort of adopting
this same attitude remember when he
tweeted last week I believe it was that
as president he wanted to share with
Russia which he absolutely had the right
to do facts pertaining to as he went on
to say terrorism and airline flight
safety basically saying that as
president when he shares classified
information it's not illegal now that
happens to be true it's true Donald
Trump any president can choose to
declassify whatever they want legally
but it is oftentimes a rogue practice
and Donald Trump appears to have no
shame about it whatsoever regardless of
the damage that it can do and it could
do some pretty serious damage now that
we've learned that this is information
that we obtained initially from one of
our allies Israel you have to understand
that it might be that an Israeli agent
or an agent that is sympathetic to
working with Israel may have penetrated
an Isis Enclave and knew about a plot
that Isis was planning and gave that
information to their superiors and
Israel until Israeli intelligence told
Jose to give that information to
American intelligence being very clear
that you don't want to spread this
around because it could endanger that
individual do you think that Isis might
not be able to figure out where that
information came from
if they find out that Donald Trump is
giving it to Russians in the Oval Office
this could actually put Allied security
people at significant risk and Trump
takes this sort of Nick Sounion approach
of hey whatever I do is fine for me to
do it's not three-dimensional chess I
would have to say and also if you
remember at the beginning of Trump's
presidency when there's a lot of talk
about if you would put his company into
a blind trust even that well I'm the
president we can't have conflicts of
interest
very very neck Sounion absolutely as
we've already talked about on the show
Donald Trump is also famous for secretly
recording people which he may have done
to James Comey in the Oval Office we
don't know
you'll recall that Richard Nixon refused
to comply with orders to release his
recordings and analogously Trump now
doesn't want to talk about the tapes and
the White House is refusing to confirm
or deny their existence we'll have to
see how the White House handles
Congress's requests for the tapes but
again another similarity to Richard
Nixon Richard Nixon getting himself in a
lot of trouble because of tapes number-3
paranoia the tweet about the quote tapes
is a display of Trump Smithsonian
paranoia his firing of Comey was a
display of his Nick Sounion paranoia the
tweets were likely not only a defense
but also a threat to James Comey the
investigations progressing Trump is
probably getting nervous about how close
the investigation is getting to him and
how the the heat might affect people
that have the ability to make deals and
give information or maybe spill the
beans on Donald Trump this sense of
paranoia something that when I think
about Richard Nixon Pat and either the
interviews while sweating and all of
this stuff the paranoia that was
transmitted there feels similar to
what's building with Trump that's true
but I think Trump has the advantage of
being a showman and having all these
years on camera because I mean you
remember Nixon wasn't too good on camera
that's why he seemingly lost that debate
against JFK I think famous from that
Trump does have that advantage wasn't
Nixon also like under the weather that
day or something maybe that was just a
defense that was given for why he was
sweaty but like you know the five
o'clock shadow that was a choice he
could have shaved before was it wearing
makeup because it was effeminate he
could have done that too right a lot
going back there and that
that that whole arrow is I mean those
those videos are fascinating I don't
know if you ever watched those on my has
on as I live
okay so the paranoia the paranoia is
continuing we we have the the Comey memo
which could end up being some sort of a
smoking gun tape you'll remember that
there was this incident during Watergate
investigations where I forget who it was
associated with Nixon I'm sort of just
going for memory here but said something
about we'll have to check the tapes and
that was the first anybody had heard of
tapes and that's when all of a sudden
those investigators said Oh tapes yeah
let's get those tapes and as we know
things really fell apart after that so
it's it's not seeming like there are
growing differences between Trump and
Nixon we're growing the number of
similarities between Crump and Nixon we
can draw some parallels already and who
knows what the next year is going to
bring as far as what we'll figure out
yeah and of course those who don't know
history are doomed to repeat it so I
think it would have been nice if Trump
before taking office maybe read of
presidential biography or studied up a
little bit and you didn't even have to
do that because Trump lived through the
Nixon administration I mean he would
have been in his late 20s when he
eventually resigned from the Watergate
he was not hanging attention he could
have think about the poetry of Trump's
photo-op last week in the Oval Office
with Henry Kissinger who was Nixon's
national security advisor and Secretary
of State and his involvement during
during and throughout the Watergate
scandal it's it's almost like Trump is
doing this deliberately with a sort of
they can't touch me attitude and maybe
they can't touch him I mean Teflon done
and that bad idea it's possible that
nothing will happen it's possible Trump
will last the full four years and maybe
even be reelected we'll see now I was
talking the other day to a conservative
minded person who's in their 50s or 60s
okay and all about this Trump Russia
scandal the the amount of things that
are just kind of questionable that you
could say put it lightly yeah and they
said I don't think it's that remarkable
or notable I mean I lived through what
happened with Nixon so this isn't
anything new to me and then I kind of
asked rhetorically well what happened to
Nixon yeah and CNN has been parading out
the Nixon associates to say hey can you
a sense of how what's going on now
compares to what what you saw under
Nixon and most of them you know it's
self selection here self selection bias
but most of them are saying oh this is
already surpassed X or Y aspect of the
entire Nixon scandal so we will continue
following it I would not be surprised if
the number of similarities continue to
grow we've got a terrific sort of new
sponsor at the David Pakman show
tag a dab the hosting specialists they
offer flexible hosting packages whether
you want a dedicated server virtual
private server cloud server options
custom server solutions they also have
colocation services tailored to your
business or project and they're sort of
big a call to action there the thing
that they're most proud of is their team
of expert hosting specialists who are
also their support team you actually are
able to get in touch through customer
support with the experts in hosting
which is a really really great thing and
they're Trustpilot rating of nine point
seven out of ten tells us how their
customers feel about them right now they
are offering a ten-pound free credit to
all new customers who want to try their
cloud services at signup CagA DAB comm /
TDPS check it out support the david
pakman show by supporting our sponsors